All
right,
we're going to mix it up this week and
talk about something a little less
controversial than usual feminism.
Everyone agrees on that,
right?
Okay,
good.
That's what I thought.
My guest this week is Christina Hoff
summers.
Christina is a former philosophy
professor,
author and a speaker for the American
Enterprise Institute known for her
critique of late 20th century feminism.
Over the past few months.
I've become familiar with Christina
because her name kept popping up all
over my twitter feed at first related to
Gamergate and now because of her tongue
and cheek commentary on campus,
free speech,
trigger warnings and safe spaces.
Actually thanks to twitter and to all of
you who've helped connect me with
likeminded people.
The show is really taken off in a way I
couldn't have imagined.
Suddenly I find myself immersed with
people I truly admire and respect.
We're all talking to each other in
various mediums and strengthening the
ideals we stand for,
even if we don't agree on every specific
issue.
One such an issue that I haven't tackled
too deeply yet is feminism and that's
exactly why I wanted to have Christina
on as an equity feminists.
Christina cares about both women's and
men's rights.
You know that whole two things can be
true at once.
Idea that I've been talking about,
I shouldn't say that feminism in and of
itself isn't one of my bread and butter
topics.
As you guys know,
I love discussing politics,
foreign policy,
religion and secularism and more,
but haven't done a ton on the topic of
feminism.
Of course,
the argument could be made that feminism
and the fight for women's rights is an
absolute through line.
Through all of the topics I just
mentioned.
Generally speaking,
where women are treated with equality,
we see fair societies with more secular
values and less radicalism.
This isn't a coincidence,
nor is it something that should be
overlooked.
Actually,
if anything,
it should be embraced.
If a society treats their women fairly,
it is almost always a more successful
society.
On every other front,
the battle for equality of women has
been different all over the world and
continues in almost every form today.
This is one of the main issues that I
wanted to discuss with Christina.
How is the battle for equality evolved
over the years?
Have there been unintended consequences
by coming so far in the battle?
Has Feminism morphed into something that
feminist of the 19 sixties wouldn't even
recognize today?
And what happens when an equality
movement actually accomplishes its
goals?
Do we move on to what's next?
There's the battle never truly end.
As you can see,
I've got a lot of questions and I hope
Christina has some of the answers.
For me,
the battle for women's rights is the
same battle that has been fought by the
other for all time.
I want women to have 100 percent of the
opportunity that men have.
I want the doors to be open and the
glass ceiling to be shattered.
Winning these battles doesn't mean it
has to come at the expense of men,
nor does it mean that men should
suddenly become less than women and at
the same time we should acknowledge the
sexes are actually different and that's
okay too.
From our hunter gatherer days to today,
gender roles have existed long before
any of us pretending there aren't some
differences in the sexist won't
magically make it true.
Perhaps we can try to embrace these
differences rather than tacking labels
on everyone and thinking that one
group's equality can only come at the
expense of another group's opportunity.
If men are from Mars and women are from
Venus,
then perhaps it's time we brought both
sexes back to Earth.
My guest this week is a speaker and
author and host of the factual feminist
on youtube.
She's known as based mom by the
Gamergate gang and just finished a three
hour conversation with Joe Rogan,
so I hope you have a little something
left.
Christina Hoff sommers.
Welcome to the show.
A lovely to be here.
Do you have a little something?
I do.
I'm just getting started.
Yeah.
So did you did three?
Did he go a little over?
Where were you with your long?
Just his little man cave there.
It was the very cozy little studio.
Well,
right before is that now we were saying
how there's this new gang sort of that
has appeared sort of you,
Joe,
Milo,
me,
a few other people that sort of have
magically connected even though just
months ago we really didn't know each
other and yet we're all talking about a
lot of the same stuff.
It's pretty cool.
Right?
Right.
And,
and I think that what we are is we're
rejecting the cultural authoritarians
and so we come from different political
places,
but we share this commitment to freedom
and you know,
just live and let live.
What happened to that?
All right,
so I want to spend a lot of time talking
about the cultural libertarians and the
authoritarians and all of that stuff.
But first let's start somewhere else.
Let's start with based mom because
that's the phrase that popped up many
times and I see people tweeting this.
Anytime I'm involved in a,
in a twitter thing with you based on
what is,
what does that actually mean for the
person?
That
first I thought it meant cool mom and I
was happy with that,
but it turns out it means something very
positive and just as good but different
in the lingo of the gamers and maybe
they got it from a rap song or
something,
but based means grounded,
authentic,
no bs they would say.
And I'm.
So that's what I am and I'm happy to be
based mom.
I like being a mom,
which I am.
And being based is obviously a good
things.
There you go.
All right.
So,
uh,
so let's start with the factual
feminist.
Let's go there first.
I want to do a little history of
feminism,
but what brought you personally to be
doing these types of videos and talking
about this stuff?
Just your journey a little.
Well,
I've always been a,
I was a professor for many years and
wrote skull scholarly articles and books
and I wasn't doing videos on youtube.
I thought that was at the time I thought
it was about,
I don't know,
cats.
It's still mostly,
but it's still mostly cat.
Yeah.
And um,
but this young man came to a Gi and
wanted to get the scholars on the air
and he did videos with all of us and
then he came to me and said,
you,
we want to put you on,
I want you to have a weekly show,
just come and talk.
And I said about what,
what are you talking about?
And he said,
it's no more than five minutes
preferably for and how do I do that?
But I started to do it and I thought,
okay,
once a week approximately,
I will go on and correct a feminist myth
because there are so many.
And I just wanted the opportunity to
reason with people to analyze some of
these factoids,
factoids.
We are in an inundated with ms dot
information,
if you excuse the pun,
just false information about women.
They tend to exaggerate.
They,
these researchers slash activist tend to
exaggerate women's vulnerability and to
overstate the strength of men when in
fact it's a complicated mix of benefits
and burdens for both sexes.
And so when they say,
oh,
women are being cheated out of twenty
three cents on the dollar and one for
being sexually assaulted,
it just turns out these ridiculous
exaggerations and the truth is entirely
different.
And so I just patiently tried to expose
the myths.
When I first started,
my mother said,
well darling,
are you going to run out of topics?
I said,
mom,
I will never run out of topics because
we have had going on,
you know,
three decades of specious research
coming out of gender studies and it all
needs to be reconsidered.
Some of it might be right.
I,
I occasionally,
I find something that's not a just
twisted into I'm a myth.
And so I,
I correct a myth every week.
Yeah.
So before we dive right into the
feminist of how do you like being in
this space,
because obviously it is new to you to be
in the youtube space and interacting
with people and twitter and all that.
I mean,
did you ever expect to be sort of a hero
to the Gamer gay community?
I want to talk about that later too,
but just being in this interesting
digital,
new thing.
No,
no,
I didn't think I would.
I remember a few years ago before I was
on twitter,
I said,
oh,
I'll never do that.
I don't know how to do that.
I just,
it was unapproachable.
Well now I can't get off.
It's so addicting.
But um,
I didn't expect it,
but I'm happy to do it because here's
the thing about that I like about
twitter,
so I don't just give a message,
I link if people are interested and try
to back up everything I say with solid
scholarship and link I linked to the
best sources I can find or to my own
work that I've done for over the
decades.
So I linked to books and articles if
people are interested.
So it's,
it's as if all of my writing has a new
life.
Yeah.
And it's also very validating,
I think to be in the space that we are
when there's so much misinformation
related to whatever,
whether it's feminism or political
correctness or any of that.
And there's so many bad actors.
I think in this space,
so it's angry people,
but,
but for us it's nice that we can be
like,
look,
here's some information and then we can
go back and forth when we want and it's,
it's,
uh,
it's very freeing to me.
I find and then when I'm able to connect
with like minded people,
I find it to be great.
I find it great and all I ever wanted as
a college professor,
I never saw it as my position to sort of
replicate my view of the world in the
minds of my students.
Heaven forbid I wanted to open the world
to them,
show them the best that was thought and
said on different contentious issues in,
in metaphysics and ethics as well as
when,
when I was teaching occasionally would
teach gender theory.
But when I taught gender theory,
I found that there was the,
the,
the closed mindedness combined with a
kind of a pension for conspiracy
theories,
paranoid theories about the patriarchy.
That didn't happen.
It's not to exist,
at least not certainly not in the United
States or western Europe.
And,
uh,
I just,
I thought if I had my ideal university,
I would take,
I would have some radicals there because
you can always learn from people that
are pushing the envelope.
Sure.
But you don't only have radicals and
engender scholarship,
it may be a bit of an overstatement,
but I don't think so really.
That's all we have.
Okay.
So before we get told that,
let's back up a little,
let's just lay out some basic
definitions because I do find that with
a lot of these people don't even
understand what a feminist is anymore.
You know,
you have your first wave feminist or
second wave feminist,
third wave feminists.
Now there's things beyond that that,
that you've coined.
I'm so,
can you just break down some of the
basic what,
what,
what was the first feminist movement?
Just give me a couple.
Well,
that would be the suffrage movement and
that was the struggle for the vote.
And then after,
when women earn the vote,
uh,
there was a period of queen essence and
we didn't hear much from feminists
throughout the thirties,
forties,
fifties.
And it came back in the late sixties,
early seventies,
and that was the second wave and it had
worked to do.
There were a lot of just arbitrary
barriers preventing women holding women
back.
They needed to be taken down.
It was obviously time to do that.
And this was more like in the workforce,
things like that.
Changing the workplace,
changing education.
I'm addressing things of,
uh,
you know,
legally for women to have more defenses
against harassment in the workplace and
so forth.
All of that.
I was totally on board.
That's just basic quest for equality.
But what happened is that the second
wave of feminism,
a lot of the women in the universities
were quite radical and they were not
about equality.
They were not about,
I see feminism,
the best of feminism.
It came from the European enlightenment
and it was about the intrinsic dignity
of all men and women and extending
equality of opportunity and liberty and
so forth to,
to all they,
many of them rejecting enlightenment.
And they're not about freedom and
freedom of expression.
And they are really.
They use their classrooms,
I think,
to promote a very rigid worldview about
how women are preyed upon by men and
it's almost as if the as if better
things got for women,
the more bitter they became,
and I watched this from close up because
I was teaching in the University of
Washington.
I kept thinking they would be
discredited because it their views will
not withstand 20 minutes in a seminar
room with some just objective scholars,
but they do not subject their research
to scrutiny of objective scholars.
They receive the evaluate one another.
Right?
So was this a strange example of where
things could exist sort of in the
academic world where perhaps they
wouldn't.
These ideas wouldn't have played out in
the real world?
Well,
they didn't and I didn't see them in the
real world and I thought they would be
contained in the academy and then would
go away.
That has not happened because partly
because of social media and these
twitter mobs and things.
It's come into the mainstream and now we
hear these words like trigger warning or
we're going to get plenty of that issue
to trigger warning before we sat down.
Oh,
we should have.
Yes,
I am a walking trigger warning.
Do you consider this a safe space?
I'm feeling fairly,
fairly frequently.
Little microaggressive pond,
but not so much.
Um,
okay.
So then that was,
that was second wave feminism,
right.
That's a good way.
Was involved into that
second wave had a radical extreme and
that extreme became the mean because
they got a monopoly on the,
uh,
professorships
and that's what you would refer to them
as third wave feminism.
The third.
Yeah.
Third way was probably the
intersectional feminism.
Are there various names for it,
but it's a,
it didn't correct the excesses of second
wave feminism.
It took those excesses and made them
even more extreme.
Yeah.
Now,
what would you say to the people that
would say,
well,
all along that ride,
even though even if they were to
acknowledge some of the things that
you're saying all along that ride
things,
basically we're getting better for
women.
So maybe there was some reasoning
behind,
you know,
there was some reasoning,
but at a certain point what you had is
just people.
It was kind of a power grab and there
were women like me can cal poly a lot of
libertarian feminist,
dissonant,
feminist.
We were just disinvited from to a party
and students didn't have the benefit of
hearing a range of opinion and
contentious issues.
Take something like something like the
wage gap it.
If you are an economist and you hear
that group a is earning less than
Groupie,
you know,
you want to know why they immediately
say discrimination.
They blame employers and the patriarchy.
But if you do the proper controls that
any competent economist would do and you
ask,
well,
how do they differ in any way?
Do all the men.
Because when you hear that wage gap,
they're just doing the average of all
the men in the workplace working full
time and all the women,
well,
men and women do not study the same top
subjects in college.
They do not work the same number of
hours.
And then on average work more hours.
They take more dangerous jobs,
women are far more likely to take a few
years out of the workplace or more.
These are relevant to your earnings.
So then what happens when we do the
proper controls and they're very good
studies.
The,
the,
the Labor Department commissioned a
fantastic study that did all proper
controls.
It gets to a point where they're just a
few cents you can't explain now.
It could be discrimination and I'm
enough of an equity feminist or worry
about that if I've been cheated out of a
few pennies or a woman are,
but chances are it's not.
Chances are it would turn out if some
innocent explanation.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
when it comes to the wage gaps and
things like that.
So I watched the whole bunch of videos
on it before I watched the video,
did it,
you did on it before this.
And partly what I think is what I think
when I watch most political things or a
almost anything related to news these
days,
I never knew who to trust.
But I watch these studies.
I say this study,
well why was it done this way?
Who funded this?
Who funded that?
How do you in the mix of all this,
figure out what to actually believe
what I do,
excuse me,
as the factual feminist,
I tried to determine,
well,
where,
who's the best source?
Whereas who sets the gold standard for
this research?
So when it comes to education,
nothing surpasses the,
uh,
the Department of Education and the
Department of Education,
they collect statistics and they,
they are very good when it comes to
crime.
Do I believe a feminist activist that
tells me that we're all,
you know,
the majority of women or,
or a quarter of women are being raped
and assaulted and battered or more,
um,
I go to the Bureau of Justice Statistics
and look at what the,
what do the statisticians who do careful
and highly disciplined as statistical
analyses,
what do they find?
And they find it something very
different and they find out the rape is
a terrible,
horrendous crime.
But it is fairly rare on the campus is
not one in four and a or one in five.
And,
and so I present that.
I show people this is what they.
These are what sort of objective
researchers have found.
These are what the advocates have found.
Now,
some people just want to believe the
advocates.
I don't understand that.
Yeah.
All right,
well I do want to touch on that in a
little bit,
but just to finish up just sort of the
waves of feminism now.
You consider yourself and you coined the
phrase,
I think equity,
feminist,
right.
Can tell people.
So an equity feminist.
I hope you are.
We all are.
Is someone who wants for women what he
or she wants for everyone?
Fair treatment?
No discrimination.
It's basically comes,
as I said,
from the enlightenment.
It's classical feminism.
It's about fairness.
It doesn't even have to be called
feminism.
It's probably humanism or people ism or
equalism had I.
that's what I assumed most people would
be for today.
Feminism tends to denote people who are
carried away with bail bashing.
If I had to reduce it to a few
sentences,
it would be a women are from Venus and
men are from hell and they seem carried
away with,
with,
you know,
female chauvinism.
I hate to say it.
Okay,
so from there.
Now let's.
Let's backtrack to what you just said
about the campus stuff,
because I know this is a place where you
get a lot of heat for this.
When you've talked about the rape
situation
to overland college and everyone was
triggered and 30 people and a dog fled
to a safe space.
They had a safe room.
There was a therapy dog apparently and
30 triggered young women and they went
to a safe room and they were so.
Which we try to plate,
parse that out.
What I mean,
what does that actually mean?
Because I know,
I know,
we know what it means and we joke about
this stuff.
I wish I didn't know what they literally
because you were coming to speak,
that I would give them ptsd now.
I have been lecturing on campuses for
years and it used to be they'd come and
argue and sometimes we part as friends
or go to a bar and you know,
kind of have a good time to like human
beings.
And if someone presents me with some
good data and good arguments,
I'll change my mind.
I've changed my mind many times that I
look forward to doing it again,
but who they are,
we're not just something has changed in
the last few years on the campus and
there's been this medicalization of,
of the,
of the curriculum and they need trigger
warnings for their classes and trigger
warnings for this and that.
And as I said,
they needed them for me and they needed
a safe space where they could retreat
because as one of them put it,
someone would be invalidating my
experience.
It's like the worst thing that can
happen to you.
Right?
So it wasn't like a good thing to
happen.
And then because you can't just go by
your experience,
you have to test it and,
and see if your interpretation holds up
to criticism.
They were not interested in,
in any kind of criticism.
Right?
So when,
when you hear this happen are new and
you see this happen to you and you say,
okay,
here's the empirical evidence about
what's happening with rape on campus.
And then they say what?
What is their counter argument?
Is the counter argument that there's
more rape that goes under reported for
x,
Y,
or Z or they're not counting,
you know,
girls that got drugged or,
or something.
I mean,
what's the,
I get that we've become this society
that's afraid of every bit of
information,
but what's the counter?
Yeah,
well they cite their own studies,
but I've spent many years and so many
other people looking at these
methodological failures.
If you,
there are ways in which I could,
we could throw together a survey tonight
and ask people questions and find an
epidemic of whatever you want.
All you have to do is ask questions that
are a little vague and it helps to,
to ask a non representative sample of
people and um,
that's what they do.
They ask,
they usually a mix of serious questions,
but then a few vague ones.
That's all you need.
Now,
does it mean your study is going to be
valid?
No.
Does it mean you're going to generate
some useful propaganda for your cars?
Yes.
Yeah.
Alright.
So I saw that,
that piece it at Oberlin.
And then the other thing that I saw you
got heat for was um,
the,
the cat calling,
right?
There was this,
this video about cat calling and you've
sort of said,
we're written about that.
This is not really a thing,
not really thing that,
well it exists,
but not a thing to be upset by sort.
Well,
it's complicated and as I said,
there are times where it's very
threatening,
but you have to make distinctions and
this is the basis of thought.
I mean,
human rationality,
making distinctions and being out in the
public square,
there are going to be interactions,
you know,
people will come up with petitions,
people beg for money,
people will say things.
It's just part of being alive.
And these control freaks think that we
can police everything that's said on the
street and they were actually suggesting
that it be against the law to cat call a
woman.
Well,
again,
I make a distinction between somebody
saying hi,
beautiful.
I mean,
frankly,
that wouldn't bother me.
It might have bothered me when I was
younger,
but as you get older you don't mind.
Uh,
but when I wish somebody saying
something disgusting or frightening that
is very or stalking you,
that's very different,
but they,
they,
to them it's all the same.
It's all a micro or macro aggression and
they want a law against it.
And,
and what I pointed out my video is that
in Washington DC,
there's a place where you can walk and
you will be cat called and I have walked
there many times and it's in a very busy
part near dupont circle and it's a lot
of women dressed for success.
You know,
when their Manolo blahniks they're
walking through and the men,
well the men are homeless people living
in this park and they make comments.
So there is a huge class difference
between these women.
Are we supposed to think these women
need to be protected from these guys who
are the have nots?
Right.
So that's an interesting discrepancy
that it's not Wall Street bankers
walking down the street making these
comments were.
Then there's sort of an added layer of,
of a financial difference in social
status and all that.
It's usually coming from people beneath,
I suppose not always offered it and gave
that enough to dismiss it.
As,
you know.
I get what you're saying.
There's a wild discrepancy between you.
You're cuter whistling at a girl or
versus leering and following you.
I
think men should know that it bothers
women.
I'm not sure it bothers all women.
I mean,
I think it depends on the woman and you
know,
it's very complicated.
Yeah.
I don't want the women who were the most
hypersensitive and for sort of freaked
out about male attention.
I don't think they should be able to
write the rules.
I think they should consult other women.
What I suspect you would find is that it
can be annoying.
I mean,
as I said,
I remember being younger and being
annoyed,
but it was mainly a.
well,
there were,
I mean,
it didn't happen that much on Wall
Street or in,
in,
in Manhattan,
but um,
so there did seem to be an element of a
class involved,
but I,
but I think you have to,
you know,
I think in different cultures the women
react to it differently.
There are different mores and things.
But in my neighborhood in Washington,
D,
c,
I don't see it happening and where I
live.
So basically what I sense is you're,
you're pretty much saying that your fear
in this would be that if you were to
allow some laws to be passed related to
all this stuff that you're handing the
power over sort of the authoritarian
police.
They can arrest anybody and it would be
these.
I mean,
I think in dc it would be these poor
guys.
And uh,
so I,
I think,
you know,
most men want to be decent human beings
and they should know women don't
appreciate it and that most don't.
And especially if it's in,
you know,
kind of pushy and certainly if it's
offensive,
but,
but then you're not,
don't make laws and don't invite the
police in this is.
There's so much of this event inviting
authorities in and some have called it
the pink police state,
you know,
this feminist police state that we have
on campus where your kids and public
universities,
the young men are afraid to tell a joke
or to say anything that comedy clubs
that are afraid to sell they veteran,
they're unwelcome on campus.
It's a hostile environment for humor.
And so that's why you have to be careful
and sometimes you'll get what you wish
for,
but then you get a lot more.
You get a lot more repression,
authoritarianism.
It's just not worth it.
Yeah.
So it's some of that also that the
feminism movement has been a victim of
its own success in a weird way because
it seems to me that feminist now should
be fighting so much more for women's
rights in other countries.
Now,
of course we have a long way to go here,
but when we see all kinds of horrible
things have,
you know,
women still can't drive in Saudi Arabia,
one of our biggest allies in the Gulf,
you know,
this is not an enemy country and all
over the Middle East and all over Africa
where women's rights are basically
trampled on if not nonexistent.
Why don't feminists groups focus on that
at all?
You do have genuine patriarchal,
oppressive societies and and what what's
happening to women's rights in Iran is
terrifying of course in Saudi Arabia,
many parts of the world.
I've been to international women's
conferences and you meet these women who
represent when then from their countries
that I've met from Cambodia and Yemen
and Egypt and so forth,
and it's very inspiring.
It's like meeting the Elizabeth Cady
Stanton and Susan B Anthony that the
feminist foremothers of their society
and you would think that the know on the
campus,
these young women would be especially
young women that are idealistic and want
to be activists.
You'd think they'd be making common
cause with those women.
Instead,
these women had overland and Georgetown
and you,
they're protesting the men on their
campus because they and they,
they feel they are,
they,
they feel that they are like these women
that are oppressed in,
in Iran,
that they have it as bad or worse.
So it's,
it's delusional.
Yeah.
So I think there's something much bigger
going on here and I think this is why so
much of our audience,
especially on twitter,
likes what we're both doing and what
people like Joe Rogan a guide,
sad and then Milo,
many others are talking about.
There's some weird movement of
Authoritarians were the left now,
which is supposed to be about free
thinking and debating ideas and doing
this right where the left is now
throwing out half the people.
I had Sarah Haider I last week and this
is an ex Muslim who stands up for every
liberal ideal.
The left should love her and they shun
her.
At best they were actually treated worse
than,
than being shunned.
When I wrote my first book,
which was protesting the,
the authoritarianism of feminism and the
Anti Intellectual Ism,
the conspiracy theories,
all of that.
Uh,
I expected to have a good reception from
feminist scholars because I just assumed
there was a silent minority of silent
majority of reasonable women.
And I did,
I heard from some great women and from
nate,
nate [inaudible] and president of the
then president of the Acl,
you,
um,
I heard from Erica Jong,
you know,
this pro-sex feminine feminist novelist
and sober and they were great,
but my colleagues in the academy were
furious that I had criticized and they
thought that criticism was the same as a
kind of betrayal and show that you were
on the side,
the side of,
you know,
the forces of evil.
So they didn't just agree,
disagree with you.
They thought you were evil.
Now they don't just disagree with you,
they think you're evil and that you give
them ptsd.
Yes.
So you give the ptsd and then it also
doesn't give them a license to say and
virtually do anything they want to you.
Because I could give you a zillion
examples of times where I've seen anyone
that shifts a little bit away from
people on the left where they are
slandered and smeared and horrible.
They do to other people exactly what
they say the right is doing.
They demonize,
they objectify,
they other eyes do use their word.
They micro,
macro there,
there,
there.
There are massive macro and micro and
nano aggression,
so they don't hesitate to be rude,
snarky,
and there's so much meanness.
I don't understand feminism with
meanness.
It was when I.
I mean I know there were some eccentric
angry women from the beginning of the
second way,
but mostly the lived experience of most
women who were enjoying their liberation
was happiness and joy and,
and being friends with men not going to
war with them.
Yeah.
So where does this strange a collusion
of all these people that all end up on
the left doing this?
You know,
I've said repeatedly on the show.
The reason I talk about this all the
time and the reason I tweet about the
regressive left and want to talk about
this because I don't want the left to go
over the deep end and that's why I'm
talking about a cross section or talking
with a cross section of people from
literally all over the world because I'm
afraid.
What happened to the right,
where it went so far?
Right?
Is,
is happening right now?
What brings these people together,
do you think when,
when often they shouldn't have a lot in
common?
Well,
I,
I will tell you what I know best is
among the feminist is a small group in
the university's gained control of the
knowledge base.
I mean what we think we know about and
women.
So you're a journalist and you need to
know something about the wage gap or you
need to know something about women and
in,
in education,
you go to these people and they are what
the journalist doesn't know or the
politician or the interested party
doesn't know is that they're spinning
and they have an ideology that drives
their research.
So I think a lot of people don't realize
that there's it,
there's so much a spurious scholarship.
So they take it seriously and now it's,
there are untruths,
exaggerations of fic,
toys,
factoids that had been repeated so
often.
They're almost beyond the reach of
rational analysis and,
and,
and if you question them,
you are by definition a sexist or worse.
So they got a certain amount of power
just through this,
this,
this information,
this scholarship about how in this case
about how oppressed women were.
So you have to sympathize and then they,
they,
they then kind of went off the deep end
with this psychobabble and these
psychodramas about.
I'm triggered and you know it.
I mean at Brown University they have a
year or so ago and there was a story
about it.
You may have seen,
I'm sure you did in the New York Times
by Judith Shulevitz at Brown University.
They had a debate.
So it was a feminist feminist,
actually a libertarian feminist and
someone else,
another feminist debating a rape
statistics and you would think that's
perfect.
What more could the students want?
They can hear both sides and their sides
well represent no,
they didn't want the debate at all and
they formed a,
a safe room.
And in that safe room they were playing
tapes of frolicking puppy dogs.
They had bubbles,
coloring books,
play dough.
Maybe I made up the Plato,
I think it was there.
So this is so infantilized and again I
and many other feminists have my agenda,
you look at it and say,
this is infantilization,
this is,
this is the opposite of what feminism
should be.
And when I got to college we threw out
the dorm counselors and the guardians of
our virtue and all that.
We wanted to be in charge.
What went wrong?
Do you think if there was a,
was there a moment that it actually,
that's something snapped.
If in fact something went wrong and the
feminist movement went from these two
extremes.
What do you think happened there?
Well,
I think I know what happened.
No one listens to me.
I wrote this article to the Aad beast
where I pinpointed what happened.
These were,
she'll call this,
these,
a fainting couch.
Feminists and purveyors of myths.
They been around for a long time.
They'd been in gender studies is too
bad,
but in 2011 at little known,
uh,
operatic,
no other,
no a government official center that was
going to sound conspiratorial if you
don't know.
But in this case it's true.
She sent out a letter to all the
colleges,
universities,
her name.
She was the assistant secretary of civil
rights,
Russell and Ali,
and she sent out to all the colleges and
I think her intention was that they take
more seriously that women are harassed
on campus and there was too much sexual
assault,
but she went overboard.
She's terrified the universities and
made it seem like if they didn't
immediately put all like most men on
trial and get them out of those schools
and believe women because she claimed
there was this app or this epidemic of
sexual predation that the men at at
campuses like Yale and swarthmore and so
we're just praying on women.
So she sent this letter and the schools
now can be sued under title nine.
This equity statute.
It's a wonderful statute.
It was meant to be there to give women
equal opportunities in education,
but it's been twisted now and they've
kind of declared martial law on men on
campus because of this letter was 2011
and you look at that date and then you
see it brought words like trigger
warnings and safe space.
This whole mindset of a rather somewhat
paranoid young women and their mentors
on campus it,
it gave them the power to to make a
federal case literally have their
perception.
That's so interesting because I can see
the line now to when you were talking
about the cat calling,
why the slippery slope exists.
If you were to create a law,
well then you could be in this.
Well now once you have a law,
they already had title nine officers,
but since 2011,
that's probably the area of greatest
growth on many campuses.
They have dozens and dozens of people
monitoring how the boys are treated in
the girls at,
at,
at Wesleyan,
in these are mostly very privileged kids
and there's a lot of drinking and I'm
sure drunk hookups,
but they have redefined drunken hookups
to at TB rape of a young man against
women.
So of course they call them.
Then there's a rape epidemic if you're
going to enlarge the meaning of this
horrible war,
but you're going to enlarge it to
include drunken hookups.
Right?
So I see.
So there's so many pieces here that,
that are related to feminism.
And so much of this authoritarian stuff
and the college stuff,
the Yale thing,
which we were both tweeting about that
happening half ago or so with the
professor that wrote the piece about
the,
you know,
the costume Halloween costumes and if
you see someone that's wearing saying
offensive,
either ignore it or use your free speech
to engage them and why you are happy
with it and hopefully have a
conversation about it.
Then that professor's a husband,
I believe is the dean there.
He got into this argument with the
student and the student basically said,
and it was all caught on camera,
basically said this is not a place of
intellectual ism.
This should be a whole home.
I really like.
It takes a lot to really get me crazy.
But I thought this is dangerous now.
What's happening,
you know.
And I also,
I usually don't feel like a Grandpa,
but I felt like a grandpa.
Like you kids.
Like how stupid are you kids?
But it really,
me as now we have something systemic
that we have to
dangerous and here's why.
Some leftist I've seen or they're
embarrassed by it,
who wouldn't be,
but they say,
oh,
it's just kids acting out.
No,
it's not just kids acting out.
These are kids who have been fed a lot
of bad,
crazy information in their ethnic
studies or gender studies where it's
highly politicized scholarship.
They've had it and they may,
if they went to elite high schools,
they probably had it since 10th grade.
They've been reading these conspiracy
theories about how bad the United States
or a western culture and particularly
the men,
it's patriarchal male had Gemini so
forth and uh,
they believe it and,
and they do not have much knowledge of
history.
So if they are doing things that people
that know history remind you of the
mccarthy era or even the Salem witch
trials just in terms of hysteria and
contagions of hysteria.
Um,
they're not aware of it.
I mean,
and what this is,
this doesn't happen often,
but there was one young woman that,
and this is all over,
not all over,
but you can find it on the Internet.
She burned my book.
She gleefully,
young woman took the organs boys and
burned it and I just,
I just,
as a teacher and a mother,
I just thought Bra burning a book,
have a good history,
you know,
now I assume that she tweeted it at you.
Well,
it was a,
it was on tumbler and someone sent it to
me.
So basically they're,
they're creating an atmosphere where
almost everything.
I mean,
it really feels 19,
84 or wellbeing reverse everything is
this sort of doublespeak and reverse of
how we're supposed to have debate,
right?
I mean,
if you can't have an intellectual debate
in college,
well how are you going to get out to the
real world and do it
right?
And the Supreme Court has ruled many
times that freedom of speech is most
important on the college campus.
It has refused to a Jew to sanction
speech codes and the courts have refused
to do this.
Uh,
but schools have them anyway.
And,
um,
it,
if our universities become places where
you have to be hyper protective of
students,
protect them from ideas,
and your goal is to achieve massive
amount of comfort and safety.
You have undermined the purpose of your
being.
You exist at the universities don't
exist for that purpose.
Going back to the time of,
of,
of the,
of socrates.
The academy was about debate and,
and counterargument and,
and being able to reason.
And,
and uh,
I think that's why people are responding
to us.
Right?
Because we're trying to bring that back.
What else do you think we can do?
Because,
you know,
I,
I see this stuff and I talk about it all
the time,
but every now and again I got,
I mean,
100 percent of the.
I do feel a little guilty ever.
It's rare,
but I do once a while,
like,
you know,
in something like the,
what happened at University of Missouri.
I empathize with these kids if they
feel,
you know,
if they were racist,
things happening inside the whole.
That thing sounds a little unclear as to
what exactly was going on in the poop
swastikas and somebody said the n word
and all this,
but I have no doubt that there is racism
on the campus and there's racism in
Missouri and in the country.
I've moved out.
So sometimes I do feel a little.
Guilty isn't the right word,
but a little.
No,
I understand exactly what you're saying.
Take it then.
I have never really gone on about the
race issues the way I do with the gender
issues.
I think they're very different.
There's a particular history,
a very specific history with African
Americans in the United States and,
and,
and I don't like to see the women's
movement pretending that they're women
have been oppressed in the same way.
That is just not true.
Depends on which women.
And if you were an upper middle class
white woman,
you have had a very different history.
And this was supposedly the great
insight of intersectional
intersectionality,
but they didn't seem to apply it very
consistently.
And certain groups,
like most men seem to be written out of
it.
So,
um,
it's just not,
it's not a consistent body of work.
They need to bring in more critics,
they need to,
to hear from dissidents and um,
if they think,
well,
ours is a compassionate movement and
they are going after people's jobs and
as I said,
there are these,
these sort of twitter mobs that want to
destroy people's reputation.
Well,
what did you make of that professor at
Missouri?
The woman who was standing there
screaming at the reporter who was,
you know,
she was saying,
we need some muscle around here to get
the reporter editor
was a thug.
It was thuggish and many of the little
scenes I've seen on the campuses,
uh,
reminiscent of a,
like these struggles sessions they had
in the cultural revolution in China.
And those were run by students.
I mean it.
People say,
well,
you wouldn't compare them.
Those people we know we're throwing
people out of windows.
I agree that I don't,
they're not comparable in that way.
For one thing,
these kids on our campus don't have that
kind of power,
thank God.
But some that I see such as,
they seem so intoxicated with hatred and
self righteousness,
I don't know what they would do if they
had power,
real power.
They have power to hurt people,
you know,
their jobs and reputations.
But that's already awful.
Look,
I mean,
it's awful what's happening to so many
young men and I have no apologies for
criminals.
They're criminals on campus and taking
advantages of,
of girls.
That's awful.
But what is more often the case with so
many that we've read about,
it's young men that,
that,
you know,
it's like a year later the girl takes a,
the young woman takes a women's studies
class and rethinks this bad hookup.
And then he's brought up on charges,
sometimes not even told what the
specifics of the charge are.
We've had too many of those.
And um,
so that's what worries me is these
people get carried away and these gender
studies and other things and then they,
they have no regard or maybe no
knowledge of,
of the first amendment of due process
of,
of the,
the history of the battle that was
fought for freedom of speech.
Now,
of course it will be turned on them.
So you're already seeing now feminists
are getting in trouble.
I think there was a professor that was
hired.
It was fired for using the f word.
Yeah.
Well now you can see that.
I mean it's happening right now.
It's turning on them right now.
You can see the left eating itself.
Right?
And if someone on the left,
I probably shouldn't be taking that much
joy in it,
but because it's been so warped,
I actually am.
I want,
you know,
as we've been calling them,
the regressives I want them to.
I want them to go the way of the
dinosaur.
Enough of this,
enough of this I know.
And we bring back it just a,
an environment of openness and with
jokes.
Yeah,
there shelby jokes.
I was,
was it?
Let's move away from some of the serious
stuff,
but now I'm going to bring up Gamergate.
So I don't know which way is this.
Serious or joking will find that tragic
comedy.
Okay.
So actually I remember very much the
first time I heard you was about a year
ago or so when Gamergate was just
starting to percolate up and I tweeted
out,
I said I want to do something about
Gamergate,
can you point me in the right direction
because I really could not get ahold of
it,
which it seems like no one still can get
a hold of,
but your name came up and Milo
Yiannopoulos and Adam Baldwin and a
couple of other people popped up and I
was looking around and I did one video
on it and I basically said I tried to
lay it out,
but I basically said I don't know what's
going on here right now.
Since then I've had my avalon and I
thought he did a pretty good
explanation.
You've become sort of a,
I guess like a heroine of the Gamergate
movement,
um,
for a lot of the reasons you're
discussing here.
So if you were going to explain it in
like two minutes,
how would you explain the,
the thing that is Gamergate?
Well,
just the first thing to know.
I am not a Gamer and in fact I've looked
at some of the games that are con and
they,
and you know,
there's too much violence and mayhem
mend.
It's,
I mean,
but I also don't like shows like
breaking bad or I can't watch them too
much violence.
So you believe they should exist if
people sort of,
not
my taste,
I do prefer,
you know,
pride and prejudice or you know,
the latest pbs,
uh,
um,
Downton Abbey,
that sort of thing.
But it's not.
I don't impose that on everyone.
And I recognized there can be great
movies.
Alfred Hitchcock was a great director
but I will never see psycho.
I'm too afraid.
It's not my,
I can't,
I don't enjoy that experience of being
terrified in the theater,
but people do it and it's theirs.
It's harmless.
And so when the video game controversy
erupted,
I,
I took a,
I took a measure of it.
I saw some familiar players because I'd
been in some of these same battles.
And I saw that,
um,
some of the feminist critics were cherry
picking.
They were misrepresenting and uh,
and that,
uh,
the gay gate was being judged by.
There are some extreme people associated
with it at the periphery,
but the CD,
but like every,
what I mean,
the occupy Wall Street,
there were crazy people on the
periphery.
Sure.
And,
and black lives matter if you go to the
periphery,
but you,
what you should do is go to the center
and what are they saying?
That's what I tried to do is go in and
see what they were saying.
And uh,
these,
these critics.
First you had critics who said video
games are causing mayhem.
They create violence.
No one has been able to show that.
And psychologists are already just tired
of it.
They're not,
forget it,
you're not theirs.
It's just going in a circle.
No one has been able to show that.
Yeah,
it hasn't.
There been some studies that have proven
it actually does the reverse because
people,
you get some of their aggression out
instead of actually shooting similar.
And it takes a lot.
I mean,
no one knows what creates a,
you know,
a sociopath,
a criminal,
but it's probably not video games.
But,
and in previous generations they thought
it was comic books.
We had a corrupting influence on the
morals of the young or it was television
and any new medium goes through this and
games seem to be there.
And then there was a feminist critics
and they were saying that it was causing
the,
well,
they were saying two things,
but the games themselves are sexist and
they,
they create a attitudes of sexism.
And I,
I just do not see evidence of that.
I did see that some of them had sexy
women and um,
but if the players like it and many of
them,
you know,
men are known to like images of sexy
women.
I just didn't understand why we were
demonizing that.
And people say,
well,
feminists will say that,
that the male gaze looking at women's
bodies objectifying which feminist I was
a part of,
a group of feminists or libertarian
feminists who it was live and let live.
I mean,
I,
I'm not against people.
There was a whole group of feminists
that were against having,
you know,
women posing in playboy or,
or the sports illustrated swimsuit
issue.
And all of that,
Catherine Mackinnon,
Andrea Dworkin,
but there was a whole group of us that
were opposed and I think we won the
argument,
but apparently they won the assistant
professorships.
They've been there ever since.
It's teaching these.
That's all they might've won
if they teach.
We won all the battles when they were
the first so called culture war.
We won the arguments.
We had the New York Times on our side.
We had new,
you know,
the media and now they've been.
They've been laboring away,
you know,
with their theories and they know
relentless and now they have the backing
of the Department of Education because
through so in the educational system
they can make a federal case of
everything.
So it's difficult.
I think in the end we will prevail
because I have great faith in just human
ability to see through nonsense.
Eventually it has to fall.
Right.
So my question there was what is
Gamergate?
And I think your answer because your
answer.
I had almost nothing to do with
Gamergate.
I think it was the right answer,
right?
Because that seems to be the confusion
about what is Gamergate?
Nobody seems to really understand what
it is.
I think at this point it's morphed into
so many details,
so many different things,
but at the core it was a group of Gamers
who were.
There were issues.
I don't understand.
It's not a Gamer.
They were irritated by some cronyism in
the race.
The magazines were being paid off by the
manufacturer.
No.
All that was going on and that that
happened.
We had,
we saw that in radio when it was a
younger medium,
there was payola and all it has to be
sorted out.
I think gaming had to go through that
and maybe it still has to go,
but it's,
it's improved since Gamergate,
that's for sure.
But then they also would find themselves
in,
you know,
getting attacked by game critics or
games evaluated because they objectified
women or something and,
and they were just thinking,
we just want to play our games.
We don't really.
Yeah.
So whatever.
And then they had these critiques of the
Games that were so cherry picked and
these gamers,
they know their games don't mess with
that and they know the games and then so
they were is of course Anita Sarkeesian
and her videos.
It was infuriating to.
And these are some young guys,
mainland some girls and they see their
games being misrepresented or she'll
pick a scene out,
make it look like one thing and was
totally different or take a video.
No one ever watched that had you know,
a following of five and act as though
it's typical of the game.
So they knew it was cheating.
They knew and they got really mad.
Now what I liked about many of them is
they,
they fought back with arguments,
they made videos,
they were,
it was,
it was this explosion of can we get
acacia now?
There were crazy opportunists at the
edges or maybe they weren't even part of
Gamergate.
Maybe no one knows who sent threats and
people on both sides of the controversy.
Get them.
Yeah.
So that's the interesting part that
there was this group of.
It's younger people playing video games.
They felt that the system that they,
you know,
they love these games,
they felt that the man,
you know,
the video game manufacturers,
they're buying the reviews and all that
and it starts with that,
but I think you just hit it that it
became this thing where suddenly this
group of people who have nothing in
common,
we,
they don't know what each other's skin
color is or sexuality is or any of this
stuff is,
but they all found this common thing
related to authoritarianism and they
fought it and that's why I was
fascinated
and they fought and they fought and
they,
you know,
it just,
it's,
it may erupt again.
It goes,
it comes and goes.
But,
uh,
there was comradery and to two times,
maybe two times we've had these gamer
gate hookups where,
because you only know each,
it's just a Hashtag.
It's not an organization.
And uh,
and in both DC and in,
um,
in London we had a meetup and I met the
gamers that and they weren't there.
You can't be a more delightful,
friendly group of people.
So that,
should that be the piece that gives you
the hope that you were alluding to a
second ago,
that there was this group of younger
people that said we're not going to take
this bullshit and if they're not going
to take it,
they were,
you know,
it was a majority guys,
but lots of fantastic young women who,
and again these are hardcore Gamers,
I dunno,
maybe 70 or 80 percent male,
but there's some fun.
The girls that are,
they're fantastic and they're part of
that group.
So they even whatever they were,
they could.
There are gay women and,
and,
and every race I mean is,
it is represented and you realize
gamergate was a consumer uprising really
from across the world across racial and
class and gender lines.
And it was just defending a hobby they
love.
Right?
So that's sort of what it is,
is that,
that's why the regressive left really
hated it,
hated it.
And they wanted to get the idea that
there would be a rebellion.
How dare you,
you do not talk back to big sister,
which is so fascinating because.
Because it was a cross section of
people,
they couldn't figure out who to guilt
into hating who more and that I think
transcends so many things that we see on
college campuses and we see in our
public discourse and free speech and all
that.
For you personally,
how does it feel as you just said,
you don't.
You were never a Gamer,
but yet you're based mom.
For these people.
How does it feel to be part of something
that you actually,
unlike feminism,
where you had a vested interest as a
woman,
let's say now you're part of something
that you want to say.
You don't care about it because you care
about these people obviously,
but as you said,
you're not a Gamer,
but you're a leader in this thing.
It's happened before I came to the
defensive wrestlers because they were.
Our sport has been demolished by it.
Completely unnecessary interpretations
of this title Nine Equity Law.
And so I made friends with a lot of
wrestlers.
I've never wrestled and I've never even.
I've never even seen it,
I don't think except accidentally
channel surfing.
Right?
Um,
but I love these.
These are just great guys and they,
they were,
and they couldn't,
you know,
they,
they didn't have a voice in this debate.
And these,
you know,
gender experts speak for the,
as if they're speaking for all women or
all of the left or something.
They speak for themselves.
People should know that.
So how did it feel?
Uh,
it,
it's fine.
It's,
I mean,
because just because everyone seems
great and I,
I just,
I mean,
as I said I haven't,
I can't think of a group of people that
were just more diverse,
more welcoming,
good sense of humor and creative.
I think,
you know,
if I were to,
based on my knowledge of gamers over the
last year or so,
it's someone's like obsessive gaming.
It's predictive of being an artist or an
engineer.
They're smart too.
It's hard to play these games.
I mean we've got the army and the navy
now playing video games to learn how to
actually do things.
So it's not that these,
you know,
I was used to,
I was running around is Mary,
oh,
eat mushrooms.
That did for me,
but nice.
So mushrooms in college.
But uh,
what about online harassment because
that is also a piece of this and it also
fits the feminism thing.
Um,
how much of it is honestly,
how much of it is real?
There's obviously plenty of it's real
and we can look on any youtube comments
section and then there's everybody
harassing everybody for every other
reason that it's endless.
How much concern should we actually have
for this?
Or is it something that is not that
important because it's just words
digital.
We should have concern for a,
just a,
a certain category of harassment.
First of all,
we have to make distinctions.
If you're online and you know,
there are different people can disagree
with you that could upset you but you
know,
live with it and people could insult
you.
That's life,
just unfollow them.
Then people can be obscene and you know,
like,
and it's probably more upsetting to a
woman than a man that kind of like
sexual and then they can issue like
really scary threats right now obviously
with the really scary threats and
probably the obscenity.
Uh,
well let's start with the threats there.
You have to,
we have to do something about that and I
think we are.
I mean I think they get reported and,
and when,
if they're credible,
but the thing is with Gabria gate and
like,
has anybody been hurt?
Is there any evidence of itch?
It's just all internet nonsense.
I mean these,
there are these threatening males and
making mean where are they?
I mean were who has been hurt.
Exactly.
I mean the worst thing I,
one of the worst things I read about was
milo getting terrible things in the
mail,
right?
Milo Yiannopoulos,
bomb threats called we have something
that he did.
Yes.
When we
did our Gamer meetup where I met the
gamers in Washington DC,
a critic of Gamergate sent,
first of all,
he sent completely rambling,
frightening notes to the bar owner
telling him not to host us and it was
very touching because it's borrowing or
was talking to me.
He was worried that what he has this
critic made it sound like,
like he was hosting some,
you know,
I dunno some Nazis or something and the
bar owner said,
what can I do?
This is America.
And he was,
he was from Afghanistan,
I think,
rooted in,
in a minute,
immigrant or maybe a rocky said,
what can I do?
This is America.
And he said,
are you going to keep us out?
He said No.
And then I,
they were so pleased because.
And everybody was very generous because
we felt bad that they got a bomb threat
and the imagine making a bomb threat in
DC.
They brought in vans and police dogs.
But of course being gamers,
we just went outside.
They partied outside.
All right.
So it had a,
it had a nice ending.
And I suppose that's all that we can do
is just,
you just keep going and you just keep
telling the truth and all that.
Which sort of gets me to my last
question,
which is I've been trying to end all
these interviews on the hope part of all
this.
Where do we go from here?
With all the things we've been talking
about?
And uh,
I think you were in a piece that I owe
that Milo is also in about the rise of
the cultural libertarians.
That there is this group of people now
that cut across the political spectrum
that include Bill Maher and rock and
people on the right like Milo and people
on the left at that have realized we got
to get out of people's personal lives.
We got to stop othering everybody.
We got to stop judging everybody based
on color and sex and religion and all
that.
I'm a firm believer that this is the
next political movement in this country.
So I guess are you with me and give me
something else
totally with you.
And I think that it was my acquaintance
with the gamers that gave me that hope
because politically they all over the
spectrum but they are very libertarian
for sure.
And this was their,
how they were acting and I just thought
that it got some insight into how they
were and and two,
because they are younger.
I mean they're gamers are a lot,
a lot younger than me,
most of them.
And that gives me hope.
And,
and I.
What I like about it too is it can unite
us from people who were concerned.
I'm still a registered Democrat,
but out of respect for my mother and
father who are so liberal,
I wouldn't dare her register anything
else,
but they.
But you can be conservative,
you can be liberal.
What unites us as Americans and maybe
he's.
Yeah,
in Westerners to it is a love of
freedom.
Yeah.
I mean that's our.
So I think it can bring people together
and we've right now it's not,
it's,
it's sort of the bullies have the upper
hand and so it's going to be a battle to
um,
take the power away from them and give
to where it belongs to people who just,
who are nice,
respectful and who want a of other
people and realize other people have
different opinions and,
and that that's okay.
And not to be policing.
I don't want these authoritarians here
who said they could make the rules,
your arguments for censorship and,
and,
and doing away with due process.
They're not going to work.
They had been tried before with that
with unhappy results.
So read some history.
But having said that,
I do think and any crazy things
happening on campus right now,
it's maybe a good thing if people are
seeing it and will not be so easy.
So ready to jump on it.
Yeah.
That to me,
that's the hope that I've been trying to
take for the last few weeks that even
even in cable news,
which is so endlessly dumb and and
pandering that I was noticing people
were starting to say,
you know,
where they'll cry racism every two
seconds and sexism and homophobia for
the first time.
They were kind of coming around and
being like,
this might be a bit much.
So that's got to be that.
That.
Yeah,
that's a good sign.
That's a good time.
Well,
what would you say?
Just the average person that,
that not someone that's in the public
sphere,
but the average person that wants to do
something about this in their,
in their.
I would suggest that you be somewhat
skeptical,
not get too carried away with a cause
until you check the facts.
Now,
if you've got good information and moral
energy,
that's moral progress.
That's Martin King.
That's civil rights.
If you have bad information and moral
fervor,
that's fanaticism and history is one
long lesson and the dangers of combining
misinformation and moral fervor,
so be careful.
Choose your costs,
causes carefully.
And um,
if you were,
if you do that,
I think it'll,
you know,
that that leads to progress to being
careful about your causes.
And right now,
if you are a woman and you a part of
campus feminism,
I hate to say this,
you have chosen the wrong cost.
It's not about liberty,
it's about repression.
Well,
you know what,
I look forward to seeing some of the
comments on this one.
We'll see if they agree with you and if
they agree,
great.
And I have a feeling if they disagree,
you'll be okay with that too.
I'm okay with that.
She gave me the evidence.
Persuadable.
There you go.
Well,
it was a pleasure meeting you.
Finally in actual life we realize we've
been doing this and this on twitter.
One hundred 40 character thing and I
really appreciated the fact that you
literally went from almost four hours
with Joe right over here.
And,
uh,
what are you going to do for the rest of
them?
I'm meeting my nephew and we're going
out for Margarita is Mexican food.
Excellent.
All right,
well,
you guys can check out Christina Hoff
summers and all the usual spots on
twitter on youtube.
It is the factual feminist.
And uh,
I thank you again and I look forward to
seeing you guys next week.